ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. I AGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAND
BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BURKE
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
GEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SUU
KYI THE SYRIAN NGUYEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA. RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE JANE
HELLO THERE IS THE APPROVED VIA
VOEPEL. WALDRON WARD WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
WE LIVE IN A NATION WHICH HAS
ROOTS DEEP IN MANY TRADITIONS
AND MANY CULTURES. HELP US- GOD
THROUGH COLLECTIVE EFFORTS TO
MAKE THESE ROUTES A SOURCE OF
STRENGTH AND NOURISHMENT. SO
THAT THIS NATION CAN BE UNITED
AND STRONG. PROVIDING SHELTER
AND A SYMBOL OF JUSTICE AND
FREEDOM FOR ALL. I MEAN. TAKE
YOUR MOM YES SIR YES OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISS WALDRON. THANK YOU
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE
ONE NATION. THERE IS A. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY REDDIT
NINETY AM THE ENVELOPE BACK
ABOUT QUE HANNAH SYSTEM SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE REDUCING THE
PRESIDING CHIEF LOOKS BACK AT
THE DESK REFLECTIVITY RADIUS
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS
OF THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS IN PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE. THE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RANDY VOEPEL. AND FOR MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM DALY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL QUIRK.
MOVING. TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MISS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS A FEW QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENTS THIS PAST
SATURDAY WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIGUEL SANTIAGO IS BIRTHDAY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WISHING HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY WHEN YOU SEE
HIM. MR SANTIAGO. LIKEWISE
YESTERDAY WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JAMES GALLAGHER'S FORTIETH
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY AS
WELL WHEN YOU SEE MR GALLAGHER.
AND FINALLY TOMORROW IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURSTON
SMITH'S BIRTHDAY. LET'S WISH
HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY AS WELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
ITEM NUMBER. ONE ACR THIRTY
EIGHT MEMBERS. THIS IS ACR
THIRTY EIGHT THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO RELATIVE TO SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS MISS RUBIO
ON THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON ACR THIRTY
EIGHT TO DECLARE MARCH EIGHTH
THROUGH THE TWELFTH SCHOOL
BREAKFAST WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN I WAS A TEACHER I
REGULARLY SAW STUDENTS COMING
TO SCHOOL WITHOUT FOOD IN THEIR
BELLIES. WHICH MADE IT EVEN
HARDER FOR THEM TO CONCENTRATE
IN CLASS AND LEARN. FOR MANY OF
THESE STUDENTS A FREE BREAKFAST
OR LUNCH AT SCHOOL WAS THE MOST
RELIABLE MEAL THEY HAD. AS WE
ALL KNOW. SCHOOL MEALS TOOK A
VERY DIFFERENT LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT IN THE PANDEMIC.
EXPERTS SAY THAT TWO POINT TWO
MILLION CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
COULD BE FACING HUNGER AS A
RESULT OF COVERT NINETEEN.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC SCHOOL
NUTRITION WORKERS HAVE
CONTINUED SERVING MILLIONS OF
MEALS TO STUDENTS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE EVEN IF KIDS HAVE
BEEN LEARNING FROM HOME. THESE
CALL THE CHRISTIAN WORKERS ARE
AMONG THE MANY ESSENTIAL HEROES
OF THE PART OF IT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO PLAY AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN SUPPORTING
STUDENTS SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
ACADEMIC CAL AS THEY TRANSITION
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM. THANK
YOU. EATING SCHOOL BREAKFAST IS
ASSOCIATED WITH POSITIVE
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE IT'S ALSO
ASSOCIATED WITH A LOWER
PROBABILITY OF THE CITY WHICH
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO MANY OTHER
HEALTH RELATED PROBLEMS. I HOPE
THAT WITH THIS RESOLUTION WE
CAN BOTH RIGHT. WE CAN RISE-
WHAT WE CAN RAISE AWARENESS OF
SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAMS AND
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE THE INVALUABLE
SERVICES OF SCHOOL NUTRITION
STAFF WHO HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO SERVE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST THE FIRST
REAL TO BE OPEN FOR OUR
PARTNERS. THANK YOU MAYES RUBIO
MISTRESS AREA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WANT TO STAND RISE IN
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK FOR BRINGING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY TIMELY
ISSUE FORWARD- COLLEAGUES
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. ABOUT 11%
OF OUR CHILDREN SCHOOL CHILDREN
WE'RE DEALING WITH HUNGER.
SINCE THE PANDEMIC THIS IS
BASED ON SURVEYS DATING BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DATING
BACK ONLY TWO YEARS AGO. LESS
THAN TWO YEARS AGO. TODAY 25%
OF OUR CHILDREN FACE FOOD
INSECURITY MALNUTRITION WHICH
AS YOU ALL KNOW LEADS TO A LIFE
OF SEVERE COST HEALTH CARE
RELATED COSTS WHICH IS GONNA BE
SHOULDERED BY THE STATE BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SO IT'S CRITICAL
FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE'RE SPENDING TO RISE. AS WERE
RISING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT WERE ALSO THEN GOING TO
TAKE ACTION IN OUR COMMITTEES
AND ON THIS FLOOR. ON SEVERAL
BILL KEY BILLS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE COMING OUR WAY ADDRESSING
THESE VERY ISSUES AND PROGRAMS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT'S BEING
DISSEMINATED IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT MORE OF OUR CHILDREN
ARE COVERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
ALL THIS QUESTION HAVING SEIZE
ON THE RESOLUTION MAYES RUBIO
YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE MS RUBIO IS ASKING
THAT THE PERSONAL THE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORSON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE THERE
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE GREEN
CARPET AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS WE ARE
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS. TO THE
LOUNGE. PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
MEMBERS AND GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE TURNING THE
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS AND CLEAR THE AISLES
AT THIS TIME. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS READ A PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK OUT A GERMAN IN MEMORY
MS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I SADLY RISE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF MY FRIEND BURNETT FINLEY
WOLFORD A DISTINGUISHED FARMER
BUSINESS OWNER COMMUNITY LEADER
AND FAMILY MAN. NICKNAMED AS A
YOUNG CHILD AFTER HIS FAVORITE
CHARACTER IN WINNIE THE POOH
TIGGER THE NAME STAYED WITH HIM
AND ACCURATELY REFLECTED HIS
ENTHUSIASM FOR LIFE. TAGUE WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN ESCONDIDO
THE THIRD GENERATION OF A
FARMING FAMILY WITH HISTORIC
FARMING ROOTS IN THE REGION.
BEGAN FARMING IN ESCONDIDO IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE. AS A
LEGACY TO THIS AMAZING FAMILY
ONE OF OUR PREMIUM- FISHING
LAKES AND WATER RESERVOIRS IS
NAMED LAKE WOHLFORD. HE
GRADUATED FROM ESCONDIDO HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX
AND MOVED ON TO BE PART OF THE
FIRST FOR YOUR GRADUATING CLASS
AT CLAREMONT MEN'S COLLEGE NOW
CLAREMONT MCKENNA. IN NINETEEN
FIFTY. DURING HIS COLLEGE YEARS
CHECK WOULD TRAVEL BACK AND
FORTH FROM CLAREMONT TO
ESCONDIDO TO WORK ON THE FAMILY
RANCHES. AFTER JOINING THE
NATIONAL GUARD FORTIETH
DIVISION HE WAS CALLED UP
DURING THE KOREAN WAR AND SPEND
TIME IN NORTHERN JAPAN AND
KOREA. HE RETURNED HOME TO
ESCONDIDO AFTER HIS ENLISTMENT
ENDED AND BEGAN ASSISTING HIS
FATHER IN THE OPERATION OF THE
FAMILY FARMING BUSINESS. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE TAKE
MARRIED BETTY MATTHEWS AND
RAISED THREE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN
IN ESCONDIDO. HE WAS INCREDIBLY
ACTIVE WITH MANY AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS AND OTHER
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. HE
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE
ESCONDIDO LEMON ASSOCIATION THE
LIMIT IN MINISTRY OF COMMITTEE
IN LOS ANGELES. AND SERVED ON
THE ESCONDIDO SOIL CONSERVATION
BOARD HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
ESCONDIDO UNION HIGH SCHOOL
BOARD AND SERVED FROM. NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. TAKE SERVE AS THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. REPRESENTATIVE TO
THE ASSOCIATION SMALL OF SOIL
CONSERVATION SERVICE. AND
SERVED ON THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
FLOOD CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD.
TAKE WAS A FOUNDER OF THE NORTH-COUNTY BANK AND SERVED ON THE
BANK'S BOARD UNTIL IT MERGED
WITH WELLS FARGO IN TWO
THOUSAND. HE WAS A LONGTIME
MEMBER OF ESCONDIDO ROTARY AND
SERVES ON ADVISORY BOARDS AT
THE SAN DIEGO ZOO SAFARI PARK.
TAKE WAS ALSO A PASSIONATE WINE
CONNOISSEUR FOR MANY YEARS HE
WAS A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
GRAPEVINE WINE TASTING GROUP
THAT MET WEEKLY. AND EVEN
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE INTERNATIONAL
WINE AND FOOD SOCIETY WHEN NOT
ON ONE OF HIS RANCH'S. TAKE
LOVE SPENDING TIME ON THE BEACH
IN DEL MAR HE WAS THE
CONSUMMATE HOST WAS HAPPIEST
GATHERED WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY ON HIS PATIO.
OVERLOOKING THE BEACH HIS FIRST
WIFE BETTY PASSED AWAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO A
MARRIED. FORTENBERRY THEY SPEND
THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR YEARS
TOGETHER SPLITTING THEIR TIME
BETWEEN THEIR HOME IN RANCHO
SANTA FE THE BEACH HOUSE AND
DEL MAR AND TRAVELS OVERSEAS.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND
DAUGHTER ELIZABETH WILFORD
MACLEOD. DAUGHTER DANA WALFORD
SON BERNARD B. WOLFORD AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN HE IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY HIS COUSIN. MARK
FINLEY TWO NIECES AND HIS
BELOVED CAT JACKI O. MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME TAKES FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND CELEBRATING HIS
REMARKABLE LEGACY.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND LOVE FILLED
LIFE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON. MEMBERS MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS YOU HAVE ALL
RECEIVED A MEMO INVITING YOU TO
VIEW THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS TOMORROW
EVENING IF YOU HAVE NOT RSVP TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YET
PLEASE DO SO. AND YOU WILL THEN
RECEIVE INFORMATION ON HOW TO
VIEW THE SPEECH ON ZOOM.
TOMORROW EVENING FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THE ADDRESS WILL BE
LIVE STREAMED AT SIX PM ON
TUESDAY. THAT'S TOMORROW NIGHT
THE PUBLIC MAY VIEW THE STATE
OF THE STATE ADDRESS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH NINTH
CHECK IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY
MARCH EIGHTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY MARCH ELEVENTH FOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN IS REYES MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH THE ELEVENTH. AT NINE AM
IN THE QUORUM CALL THIS LIFTED.